but i do have some good news i'm not
going to be constantly negative because
we got news
ladies and gentlemen this one's big from
abc
what is this is okay it's interesting
this is from abc 17
fox 22 both at the same time there you
go
minnesota man sentenced to four years in
prison for role in setting a blaze a
minneapolis police precinct
during floyd protests they say dylan
shakespeare robinson 23 pleaded guilty
in december
to one count of conspiracy to commit
arson for taking part
in setting up police precinct in
minneapolis on fire on may 28th days
after floyd was pinned down and you know
we know the story
robinson was sentenced wednesday to four
years in prison
and two years of supervised release
according to a news released from the
news release from the district of
minnesota's u.s attorney's office
he was also ordered to pay 12 million
dollars in restitution
robinson's attorney has not responded to
cnn's request for comment so i guess to
cnn's story
you want to know why this story is funny
because he only got four years do you
want
but you want to know why he got any time
at all because he burned on the police
station
that's right because when push comes to
shove the system will protect itself and
not you
what about the people who burn down the
sports bar what about the people who
threaten the guy in his home and this is
in portland a guy
he's got an american flag at his house
they go up to his house and start
chanting just random guy
and they start yelling take the flag
down or burn your house down no charges
there
people in dc they actually got paid for
it so
i know this guy's a he's a local
celebrity and you know that right oh
they love him yeah he's gonna be a
political prisoner to be a hero
and when i was when i was in minneapolis
a couple weeks ago
and uh the specifically black lives
matter cause sometimes people throw blm
like very loosely you know this was blm
in minneapolis one of the activists one
of the leaders got up and was like
you all know that some of these are
they're being they're facing charges
of arson because they burnt down that
police station last year
she's like yeah you know you guys all
remember that she's like that was that
that stuff was effing epic
they love it so what do you think
happens he's a celebrity
in in four or five years okay so maybe
trump run trump you know trump is
talking about running again in 2024
i don't think trump's got the uh
gumption to actually get the job done i
don't
i think a lot of people thought he was a
fighter turns out not not really
i mean it's better than biden it's
better to have someone who's resisting
the system than supporting it
but i don't even think trump's got what
it takes maybe ron desantis does
but what do you think happens if trump
doesn't win if they continue to gain
more and more power this guy is going to
get out
and when he walks out there's going to
be local politicians clapping and
cheering
they already voted to abolish the police
they kind of backfired now they're
desperate for cops but what do you think
happens if this if this ideology keeps
protesting a slow boil
by the time this guy in four years is
getting out of jail the local mayor is
going to be like you're a hero and we're
so sorry that you're a political
prisoner
you get released i think because what
the mainstream media
has done is they this is why you see
this on cnn msnbc abc
they'll always call them either peaceful
protesters or they'll call them
just protesters right protests erupt
after the shooting of uh dante wright
right every single black person that
gets shot
protests even fox will say this protests
erupt protest
and they'll show up a picture of like a
building burning down right yeah but but
but listen to the
the my my theory on this if you
if you're constantly putting the
narrative out that these are
protesters whenever the headline comes
out the next day that
a hundred people got arrested that
sounds horrible
right a hundred protesters got arrested
last night
for what expressing their first
amendment right of freedom of speech
and to peacefully protest right that's
just the narrative
but it works because nobody wants their
name attached to the headline the next
morning no mayor
no d.a no police depart nobody wants
that headline the next morning saying
a hundred protesters got arrested last
night
for expressing their first amendment
right nobody wants that but
that's the propaganda but that's why in
my opinion it works that's why they get
away with writing
that they get glorified when they burn
down a building antifa is continuing to
burn down
police union buildings with people in it
the only reason or i should say one of
the strongest reasons one of the main
reasons
that people in major urban metros keep
voting democrat
is because the cops are propping the
system up
what do you think what happened when
they voted to abolish the police in
minneapolis
crime skyrocketed and locals started
panicking
calling their city councilmen being like
what's happening where are the police
why is this happening
and then all of a sudden these
pro-abolish the police people come back
and say we we need our cops back our
constituents are freaking out
did the uh portland cops just all 200
resign like today
was that seattle over the past several
months okay so imagine what would happen
if the remaining cops were like you're
on your own
this is what i was talking about with
lydia on the drive here from the airport
is i think there are times in history
where you're either going to learn from
you know data facts knowledge wisdom
and make your decisions from there or
you're going to have to learn through
experience
so i think right now america is so
spoiled so self-entitled
where socialism is like and communism
are like glorified ideas but we have no
idea
what it feels like to live under
something like that
i think right now we are going in a
direction tim where
as a christian i think i believe we're
either going to experience some kind of
spiritual revival people are going to
come to christ and things are going to
change or
i think we'll probably have some kind of
civil war people are going to push back
and say enough is enough we're fed up
with the communists
get out of here right or i think we're
just gonna have to continue going down
this path
people are gonna keep voting blue people
are gonna keep supporting these radicals
people are gonna keep virtue signaling
bowing down to black lives matter and
antifa
right and we're just going to have to
get burnt because i think right now the
country's going in the direction like
you said minneapolis like
but bosh the police oh maybe that wasn't
such a good idea
you know like so i think on a grand
scale that's where we're going where
i think we're going to have to watch the
republic fall in order for us to
pick up the pieces again and just say
that's what they were i know that's what
they i trust
that was their mission that's that's
their mission that's their goal but
people don't realize that like you said
like you you were telling me earlier
people aren't listening
they just don't care it's like okay well
you're gonna care when these people are
knocking down
your down door knocking down your damn
door at night when they want to take
your life and call you a white
supremacist but
like i said i think we're going down
that path where it's just gonna have to
get to that point where people
feel it they feel what these ideas do
and until you get there you're not gonna
really understand so as long as the cops
are still around to answer calls
for the uppity white progressives who
are leading the charge and making all
this bad stuff happen
the same people who say abolish the
police are the ones who yell call 9-1-1
when they're threatened
and then who suffers the poor the
minority neighborhoods
the ones who according to gallup are
saying they want more cops but
won't stand up and actually actually ask
for them i'll tell you this here's a
simple compromise
if you're a cop just don't answer any
calls to uh
these uppity progressive areas if if you
get one of these
you know wealthy liberal areas saying
you know help someone's breaking into my
house i'll be like well do you have a
gun
no no geez i was i was like i guess i
was talking about this with some
some of my some of my buddies in
minneapolis and i was just like you know
i don't know if i would i say this out
loud but i'm gonna say it out loud
would it have been better for derek
shelvin to just let george floyd go
yes well we don't know because if he was
really high on fentanyl and he was
getting behind the wheel of a car he
might have killed a family that's true
too
but i i i understand well like there's
so many things that could go wrong and a
cop
is obligated to think about that right
but what i'm trying to say is i think
cops
are starting to ask themselves was
was that even worth it i mean i'm i am i
am going to lose my life
i'm going to lose my family i i am going
to lose everything
over a guy that had a 20 counterfeit
bill and it led to
the fbi gonna come out uh the fbi was
interested no matter what
everyone agrees on at this point well i
should say for the most part
the left has been saying that the whole
time who cares there's a 20
bill let him go but there's a bigger
issue the guy was doing drugs
behind the wheel of a vehicle and now
you've got some serious questions about
like ian said what if he yeah hit
somebody i agree i agree with that
especially the way that i think that's
the first thing that where my mind goes
to
have a fentanyl addict that could get
loose in the community and he could
literally
wreak havoc right but it would have been
objectively better for the cops not to
have responded
and from this point on not to respond at
all yikes that sucks what i think people
are asking themselves and it's like
i i personally think the answer to that
question is no
but i'm just putting that question out
because i think that's what a lot of
cops are beginning to ask themselves and
it's just another subversion
of law and order but it's it's it's such
a crazy situation
because another thing that i wanted to
point out and i want people to
understand is
all you hear from black lives matter is
that george floyd
uh died because he was black okay even
the head of the prosecution went on 60
minutes the other night and literally
claimed that this was not a hate crime
that they had zero evidence to prove
that george floyd was targeted because
of the color of his skin
this is part of the propaganda that is
leading to people burning down buildings
okay committing mass looting mass arson
that's all you hear tim you know what
i'm talking about whenever you're at a
blm
rally or antifa direct action black
people getting hunted
black people getting shot black people
are dying at the hands of police
officers
it's it's a fact it's a fact the
prosecution
admitted george floyd did not die
because of the color of his steve nelson
said it
why wasn't he charged with the head of
the prosecution there was no evidence
there was no evidence
yeah well but look where we are right
abolishing police
burning down buildings rioting causing
over 2 billion
of damage in 2020 alone over a lie drew
i think that
i honestly am starting to think that
what happened in minneapolis needs to
happen to every city where these
uppity white progressives are calling to
abolish the police you should
have that moment of fear where you need
to call the police
and nothing happens yeah i don't want
riots i don't want buildings being
burned
i just want people to like they'll see
someone walking through their
neighborhood and they'll call the police
and the cops are going to be like
good luck yeah that would be good if
everyone had to psychologically
experience the trauma of not
having police but my fear i love the
idea of police
and military refusing to serve a corrupt
regime that
i love that idea but what terrifies me
if all the police
vanish tomorrow and all these private
cops and
federal cops come in to fill the void
and it becomes it's worse than it was
before would be worse
because private cops don't have to
adhere to the city okay i stopped to
adhere to the law it's supposed to yeah
ian the cops that we have right now
people who are serving out bad laws
people who are doing unethical things
are essentially mercenaries
so you want to talk about someone who's
paid to do something that's not
moral not ethical and that's not a
single eye when they're asked to do
something like arrest a little tiny old
lady
i think ian i think you're wrong because
if someone calls police hut
i'll call you know palisi's junior oh
yeah and i'll have my my you know police
huh is that what you're saying but
you're two months behind on your policy
junior bill so oh i won't be yeah
well yeah i won't be so so a lot of
people are talking uh i see a lot of
comments where people are saying
there will be a vacuum of power without
the police department
do you live in a big democrat urban
metro well then i'll tell you this
you shouldn't i left we all left we were
in the philadelphia area and i was like
man i see where this is going
i'm out am i really that worried about a
power vacuum in the middle of nowhere
where there's already no power structure
other than people in their own homes
on large multi-acre properties who are
armed to the teeth
ain't got nothing to worry about out
here good luck coming to west virginia
and having a go with a riot in one of
these neighborhoods these
these people live in west virginia
there's there's facebook group chats
there's text chats
and the moment they don't they don't
call the cops they just text the group
they're like hey you know i saw somebody
keep your eyes
keep pressing on the lookout some of
these people
scare me they're like oh man you know
the cities are so lucky
can't wait for these people to come out
here i'm like nah you don't want to say
that dude that's that's freaky we don't
want to do that
but i'm not worried now i'm not worried
in the least bit
we don't we don't have a police station
out here in the same way a city does
we're in a place where you call the cops
they'll be there in what
an hour i mean that might be true in the
cities too by the way because
cities i don't know they're pretty
crummy in a lot of ways
so power vacuum in the city well the
people who voted for this
and keep voting for democrats hey that's
on them if you think there's gonna be a
power vacuum
filled by a bunch of corrupt private
cops gangs
and woke police do you live there
i mean i'm sure a lot of people do and
they're probably freaked out by this but
at a certain point take responsibility
and get out
i mean look like like i've been saying
your house is on fire
now we we all fought very hard to to
reject that fire and shut it down
now it's clear the fire is engulfing
your house now you need to go outside oh
but it's cold outside i know
but what about my family they'll freeze
that's true but they'll burn to death if
you stay inside
so maybe it's all right to that point
where all these cops are leaving crime
is already skyrocketing
you want to tell me there's a power
vacuum have you been paying attention to
the crime rates in
all major cities across the country
shootings are up like 250 percent or
something in new york
why are you still there well look if
your house is on fire no one's coming to
save you you got to save yourself
maybe that's the point about these
people living in these cities for
everybody else who kind of lives outside
the cities or in the middle of nowhere
what are you worried about or get out of
the blue states at the very least
stop living in places where they put
their boot on your neck and let
criminals run rampant
i think i think that goes back to what i
was saying earlier is i think police
officers have to make a choice
you have a constitutional oath to
protect and to serve the communities
that you work under
and i think it goes back to also like
the leadership if the leadership is
setting you up to fail
miserably to the point where you can't
even protect yourself in some cases
you look at portland i'm in contact with
portland pd on a daily basis almost
and they always tell me the mayor is in
control of all of this
we get our hands tied behind our back we
can't even use the type of
riot training that we've been trained to
to use
to stop these people and then you see
the footage and it's just cops getting
milkshaked just humiliated the
psychological abuse that goes into that
as well
i talk to them this is what they tell me
they live in fear they they fear their
lives they fear
uh antifa finding out where they live
but the point i'm trying to make is
i think i think tim is what these these
these police officers do have to
sincerely consider
am am i walking into a profession where
i'm being set up to fail now
i think anyone would be like i'm not
going to work for that i don't care
about these cops in portland
i saw the video of the blue lives matter
people getting shoved by cops while they
protected antifa who had pepper spray
you think i'm going to give any sympathy
to the guys who are shutting down small
businesses
arresting a guy for handing out a beer
or or shoving and pushing
the peaceful right-wing protesters who
actually support the police
nah that's the problem the da will throw
the book at someone on the right
and they'll let someone left go with no
charges and the cops will arrest both
and say don't look at me
that's what i'm so antifa goes around
throwing fire bombs setting fires
and then when the when the right wing
group shows up the cops form a line hold
their batons out start shoving them and
yelling
and it was funny to see the look on the
face of these conservatives like why are
we being attacked by cops yeah and then
taking the blue lives matter flag
throwing in the dirt and stomping on it
yeah and
and i agree that's why a lot like i told
you a lot of conservatives don't like me
when i talk like this
because i'm not 100 back to blue because
i don't support crooked cops i don't
support unconstitutional cops
i support cops that support their
constitutional oath
and they actually protect and serve the
communities if that's not what you're
doing you need to resign like tonight
because that's what you have been called
to do that's what you've been hired to
do
and if you are being put in a position
where you cannot do that then
then i know this is a lot easier said
than done you got to really reconsider
if this is the profession that you want
because now we live in a generation
where lawlessness is now abounding
that means that you have to be a crooked
cop to survive now
it's a pretty radical thing to have to
swallow but that's where we are
the media is lying antifa is not real
the politicians it's just an idea and
the district attorney's
you're free to go all of this is only
possible
because cops are protecting those who
keep pushing for it
plain and simple it is the uppity white
progressives in big cities who are
voting the democrats
giving them this power and they're only
able to do it because cops are standing
guard while antifa burns down minority
neighborhoods in poor neighborhoods
yeah it's like that funny tweet from
that guy who was like
yeah go riot woohoo wait a minute oh no
they're coming to my house in beverly
hills help stop
don't do it you see what you see you see
what happens to these people
the moment the riders show up to their
neighborhoods but it's okay
because i assure you the cops will be
there to protect the rich people i love
it in in
in manhattan during hurricane sandy and
the power gets shut out
i tell you the first place to get their
power back do you know which part of new
york had their power back first
upper west side all the very very rich
people in the university
got to put their feet up while the
people in the poorer areas in brooklyn
didn't have power i think it was for
like weeks regarding um
being set up to fail which it does seem
like a lot of these cops are
by these district attorneys when you're
in like high stress situations
people will do crazy things when they're
being set up to fail like in world war
one they'd be told to go over the
trenches they would just eventually just
mutiny and not go
in vietnam if you had a lieutenant that
was going to take you
down a trail where you knew you were
going to get shot that lieutenant would
find a grenade in his tent in the middle
of the night they called it fragging
for a reason because they would kill
their commanding officers if they were
going to
get them killed now we're not in that
high stress situation domestically right
now and the cops
aren't in the military they can resign
and
at what point chauvin had his life
destroyed because he tried to
this girl that shot the guy that was a
girl that was about to stab someone or
that guy that
oh yeah his life's going to be torched
because he saved
him kim potter was trying to make an
arrest on a guy who was wanted on an
aggravated robbery warrant
who was armed and she shot him one time
and he died
and now she's going to go to prison kyle
rittenhouse
watched his community get burned
i'll i'll be very careful for juan
williams watched businesses all
throughout his community burnt
get set on fire they almost blew up a
gas station
so and drew is there and he shows up and
a friend gives him a weapon
he even rendered aid to the extremists
now he's i think he's going to get life
in prison i do he'll get life
no jury is going to is going to do
anything for
justice or principle they're going to be
like you know what the kid can can go to
prison for all i care i don't want to
get hurt
because of demoralization and it's only
possible because there are cops who
arrested him
because they're like well you know it's
the system at what point is there
someone who's going to be like
there's right and there's wrong thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time